like the the volleyball pipeline is like
you play until you're 30 35 and then you
know half make no money right and you
make no money yeah and I was thinking
I'm like how silly is it I'm like I
spent my early 20s chasing a career that
makes
zerar that's like that was like men
would never no it was a lot of fun and I
loved it but it's like weird looking
back it's like literally travel
volleyball you're gone 2 weeks a month
you spend like two I spent 2 to four
hours a day like working out since I was
like 12 years old and yeah so I was just
thinking about it and I'm like it's and
it's all by like lesbians that run a lot
of this stuff and like yeah and then and
then it's like your family is the team
it's not your actual family